so mr. Vadra check when asher comes here
what will happen to him in this room how
does it all work how does it all work
well first you coming as a patient I am
as I understand so you have to like wear
a stiff I'm still on the table then the
table with this is a robotic couch with
six degree of freedom so it's very
precisely working it position you very
precisely at the place you have to be
according to the beam and so you get a
molded yes body shape which yes you
can't move around you can't read yes yes
you have weight force you to stay in the
position you were started to be treated
so as you come several times for
treatment you have to lay exactly the
same position each time so that's why we
have this fixation here to make you lay
the same way you're lying
all the time and every individual
patient has yes yes exactly
Ashley will get one made specifically
for him exactly yes okay so he's in the
cocoon he's under the machine what
happens what are you looking for how
does it work she was how it will well
first you have to be precisely sure that
you are treating the right place because
it's just positioning of the patient is
not precise enough so we have the x-ray
imaging which is orthogonal x-ray
imaging you here on the machine so you
can directly see inside the patient if
you are in correct position if you are
treating the right place so as I have
shown you this is the this is the flat
panel which is going out of the machine
inside this nozzle there is a there is
an x-ray tube which makes the images of
the patient and the treatment position
so now you are 100% sure that the
patient is laying in precision better
than 100 meter for human is enough so
then you can start the treatment
so you position the machine to the
correct angle the nozzle can rotate
around the patient so you are sure that
you are treating the right place from
the right direction so this goes all the
way yes yes I can show I can show ya so
the basic thing is you
a treatment plan you have to follow so
you know from watch angles you have to
treat so the machine is able to go to to
the position you prescribe with very
high precision I must say so you're
moving the proton beam correct into the
correct position yes and then at some
point do you press a button and fire it
out is it yes yes exactly
if you are sure or we have this a hero
verification system the computer system
which which also controls if the
position of the machine and setting
coupled emission is correct according to
the treatment plan and afterwards you
are fine with the patient positioning
and the machine setup then you press
just the button at this point you have
to call for a beam it's a computer
software so you ask for the beam and the
beam is from the cycle time directed to
this room so outside of here there's a
huge accelerator that is creating the
beam basically what is huge is the
gantry behind the accelerator itself is
yeah it's quite huge as well it's I
don't diameter of let's say 7 meters
it's 22 tons of weight and but this is
the place where the protons are
accelerated then they are directed to
each of all treatment rooms we have four
of them so you direct over energy yes
that machine yes into the patient
exactly exactly and how long does that
last wall depends on the number of the
fields our filter and also on the field
size somehow but usually the treatment
itself I mean when the beam is own it's
just some couple of minutes
what takes a long time is the patient
position and precise patient positioning
loading the patient on the robot and
position again and then also unloading
and putting the patient out how often
does that happen do you do that five
times a day or five times a week or once
a day how often can you take the beam if
you like well we can take any well it
does not matter because if you have a
patient just as the beam and even have
it so this is how it works but as far as
the patient is concerned apart from the
you know that it's being aimed at it's
not doing any damage at all to anything
else well each variation does some
damage some collateral damages other
than proton beams the quarter of damage
is quite low the lowest from all the
radiation types you have now available
so for a five-year-old boy yeah with a
brain tumor coming here how many
sessions is he likely to need and how
long would that take as a period of time
well as far as I know it is about 30
fractions or 30 sessions of treatment
and each treatment takes all depends if
the child is in anesthesia or not but
each treatment takes let's say 40
minutes I mean the whole session
including the including the loading
positioning treatment and unloading and
that would happen what once a day or
more than once a day once a day usually
so 30 days every day of about 40 minutes
of 3 years yes and at the end of that
all being well he will be cured yes whew
yes as our experiences yes